[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
enfin les enfants boers soir bonsoir
mais oui ce soir je vais raconter une
histoire à mes petits amuse une histoire
qui s'aiment beaucoup tupi typique où
les chars
du petit tu piques
boussouar mes enfants
oui une histoire de philippines et du
lapin blanc oui j'aime beaucoup les
histoires à toi aussi juliette à
lillers qui s'est passé avec un instant
je me pose
et bien voilà la petite philippine et
retrouve son lapin blanc sib it est
partie
un beau matin sans rien dire et il est
introuvable mais écouter la suite
filippi décès par an on avait fait des
voyages et partout où il passait
philippines à plein débit car elle avait
perdu 100 meilleurs amis le lapin blanc
et leur recherche est partout au moins
les lapins je le mets dans des cars au
début du elle jouait du trombone
tibi tu me dis je jouais encore du temps
bout
du bout du bout du petit bibi et joie
toujours du tambour
tibi le lapin blanc ne revenait jamais
ce lapin blanc est introuvable
rentrons chez nous décida le papa sur le
chemin du retour bien fatigués ils
s'assirent un soir au bord d'un talus
est en fait un drôle de lapin blanc
crème ni manger toutes les frais de mon
jardin c'est qu'il ya tout près d'eux
une fermière en colère
alors philippines bondi lapin blanc mon
lapin blanc et le lapin blanc sortir de
sa cachette sont a aussitôt dans les
bras de la petite fille
et vidic début du début des notes et
dudu philippine avait enfin retrouvé son
ami et la petite fille ronde et coquine
était la plus heureuse des petites
filles auront deux coquines il était
temps qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
payer avec son ami le lapin blanc qui
lui s'est souvent des farces mais qui ne
se sauve plus car il habite maintenant à
la campagne dans une maison tient grand
jardin plein d'arbres de fleurs
et deux frères
[Musique]
alors et vous a plu mon histoire oui
beaucoup
l'espagne est à
mais c'est pas la dernière avec
philippine et les lapins blancs minimum
non ils ont encore de nombreuses
aventures que je vous raconterai
tenue je vous donne le livre ce cas là
ça m'a fait presse pour ma collection
nos prisons nous allons y seuls
28 91 nounou de nuit mes chers petits
[Musique]
depuis tu débutes du début d'une ma
parole mais c'est le lapin blanc menon
patron ce mois nounours hop hop hop hop
hop je vous ai bien notre open allons en
route gros farceur bonnut les enfants
embrasser bien fort vos parents faites
votre toilette n'oubliez pas de vous
laver le draw et feu de pur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]